[Music]
all right week six is in the Bucs
getting ready for week seven we're
recording this on Monday
lef koe man and Westbrook so we haven't
seen Monday night
it's Green Bay Detroit yeah so if you're
listening to this now hope the game was
phenomenal but I'm looking forward to
that game oh it's gonna be great
I just you know we're over here we're
talking about diapers and baby poop and
that's how I felt at his Sunday watching
games yeah of all the Sunday's this was
my worst one this is my easily my worst
one there was some surprising thing I
went oh and four of my picks yeah I see
that face she just made money [ __ ] the
Titans Mariota get the hell out of here
you feel good about the Titans though I
thought I did and then let me just say
this that at one point of the afternoon
in the one o'clock games three teams
that I had bet on were up 54 to 12
Kansas City was up 17 to 3 and heavily
Volyn was up 20 to 6 Washington was up
17 to 3 Fitzpatrick as soon as I heard
Fitzpatrick was in the game over I was
like he's the best tanking quarterback
of all time he's gonna get them right
down there and then and like I'm
watching with the kid and he was like 1
oh they're gonna go to overtime I said
it's [ __ ] they're tanking you're going
for two
yeah didn't get it Baker may feel the
Browns like four turnovers O'Dell I
don't care if he had over a hundred
yards but no good and the referees in
that game Kansas City the referees in
that game what about the Dallas game you
want sit down as game last night right
yeah I mean the last the last drive with
the Cowboys to where they were trying to
get them to cheer didn't feel like it
yeah oh oh
sides on a DMA everything that you could
possibly call Warren Sharpe put out this
morning on the Kansas City interception
in the end zone it's an up and back game
Patrick mahomes sees Travis Kelce get
tackled and goes I'm throwing the ball I
got a free play they call a pass
interference but if you go on to sharps
Twitter account up short
football you see one point where the
referee while talking puts his hand over
his ear they are clearly communicating
with the refs on the field no doubt I
watched a Jarvis Landry touchdown where
the ball went over the plane get called
a non touchdown it [ __ ] it man it sucks
like I know it goes both ways here like
I know that there's a lot of teams that
I've been on in the past where I've
gotten it but it still doesn't make it
any better and it's every game I'm
watching that end to the Cowboys Jets
game was so blatant crazy but also like
earlier in that game they called a pick
play on Witten and it wasn't even good
lives I just I just don't know what
they're looking at and it's like that
every week thing Brian we could complain
about the refs every week I think as we
get deeper and deeper we'll have more
games of reference like you didn't call
that a week three you didn't call that
last week and so it will continue to get
worse and worse as it goes on we are
going to get a little bit later I had a
premonition and I know who's gonna win
the Super Bowl really we're gonna get
into that type of good we are going to
get into the forgotten MVP race and
everything that's everyone's talking
about now and we are gonna go through
division by division and figure out who
is the best team in every division it
really feels like kind of the NBA where
it's a bunch of two-man teams out there
that's what every division feels like
but first we need to start with the most
important segment in NFL today dolphin -
yes this is my favorite favorite
favorite favorite segment me too let's
go man how did I buy anything last week
you always buy something could welcome
back to the segments that grow vine of
rounds who then immediately fixed it
this is dolphin Tech first into the tank
an NFL team that's been left
but left of things that with the right
investment they could win their division
I mean they absolutely cannot but what
do I know
I'm just the voiceover guy I have a team
for you today Brian Westbrook that has
suffered some critical injuries so
they're gonna get used to it and bounce
back they're just two games back in
their division race this team thus far
has played the fourth toughest strength
of schedule so maybe the record isn't as
bad as it looks
the team that leads their division
currently has played the easiest
schedule in the NFL maybe they're a
little inflated this team lost by a
combined six points to the Niners and
Seahawks who are a combined 10 and 1 hmm
I think who are a combined 10 and 1 will
you buy into this disgraced former
legendary team so basically the team has
a losing record right now but they
played a tough schedule very tough
fourth toughest in the NFL and I think
that plays a big part and so the hard
part is you got to look at the injuries
and over that tough schedule the
injuries and how those injuries have
impacted this team
yes now they lost some of their best
players yeah so on this stretch yes are
they coming back no no in that case I'm
not buying them you're not buying no
with me but I guess what team was no
yeah you the ring like you're like tom
from civilization
it is the Steelers this dealer yes so
here's the deal they lost what live and
you look at their losses they lost at
San Francisco my for now granted they
had the diners had five turnovers and
still won by four they lost at home to
the Seahawks by two yeah and if you
remember it was an incredible Russell
Wilson performance late
they obviously lost to the Patriots
another top team and their loss to the
Baltimore Ravens they lost in overtime
and they went down to their third string
quarterback in that game they're going
into a bye they're coming off a very
impressive win over the Chargers and I
just as someone that's been you know
saying Ravens Ravens Ravens
there is a chance I don't think it's the
Browns I definitely don't think it's the
Bengals that if the Steelers with that
defense if it could come alive it could
get really interesting that defense has
looked better James Conner looked much
better last night so are you more
interested now that you know that no
Steeler I think the Steelers will end up
being the second best team in their
division
I think they'll end up beating out
Cleveland ok put being the second best
team in that division but you don't see
them getting ahead of multiple no ok no
though you can't I mean you're going to
your third quarterback second
quarterback coming in and that defense
has to be good for a long time and
consistency at some point defenses we're
gonna say listen we're just gonna stop
James Conner and make this young
quarterback win the game right and
that's gonna be a problem we forget that
Devon Bush returned a fumble for the oh
wow they had $24 actually it's seven
deer but it will be interesting to watch
cuz that defense now Stefan - it did get
hurt last night or on Sunday night so we
will see let's go back to the dolphin
tank yeah try and son you know before we
go on the Steelers it's impressive
they're combining a couple running backs
now that's gonna help them a lot Snell
get nice know which I didn't know he was
even still playing but yeah I'm glad
that he's playing well young guy I just
think that having that running game is
gonna help him a lot yeah and just
didn't play on Sunday night so see when
he gets healthy back to the tank next
into the tank left goes got an
outside-the-box choice for Offensive
Rookie of the Year he's been a beast on
one of the top teams and yet you still
won't pick him up in fence
- that cater hater that really cut deep
that hurts me this is a player that some
people thought could have been a
first-round pick and slipped to the
second round and his team entered the
season with super bowl dreams and they
now stand at five and one his position
was a monster question mark and he has
filled in perfectly what do you think it
is and are you buying so he's a five on
one team to the second round looking
around his position was a monster
question mark he's filled in perfectly
and the team is now five on one he's my
early pick for efforts of rookie the
year that I don't think anyone's talking
about do you buy it and who do you think
it is five in one team so there's only a
couple of those Seattle's if I were one
team right yep Raiders is not okay if
he's filled in well yep the team needed
him yeah is he one Seattle I don't know
are you buying I'll tell you after yeah
yeah if it's a position of need and he's
filled in well yeah I'm buying them so
okay great so who do you think it is my
first guess is is Metcalf yeah that's
what I wanted you to think it's not what
is it yes it is Saints Center Erik McCoy
what say who talks about offensive line
nobody cares about the offensive line
here on the Left Kosho we're here to
teach before Sunday in 207 pass blocking
snaps he has allowed four hurries he has
not allowed a sack he has not allowed a
hit I went back and I watched the
Jacksonville King Erik McCoy played
nearly darn perfect and as they've lost
Drew Brees and they've had to win for
Noah Teddy Bridgewater president the
only issue that I had for the Saints was
that their longtime starting center the
one that they traded Jimmy Graham for
max Unger was leaving and I went I could
see this whole system falling apart
if this rookie out of Texas A&M doesn't
pick it up and he did and no one is
gonna talk about him and we're gonna
talk about the Terry maclaurins and
we're gonna talk about the DK Matt Cavs
about and we're gonna talk about all
these outlet Madison these young ballers
but the most in
horton position to that team in terms of
getting that offense to flow with Drew
Brees it's gotta be this guy and no
one's talking about it and I know it's
out of the radar but I think if anyone's
gonna talk about it
it's the love coach well I'll tell you
this I I do appreciate offensive line
play and I've been brought up under the
thought process you win football games
in the trenches offensive and defensive
line so when you have a young guy and he
just imagine the the center is the
quarterback of the offensive line he's
pointing out who's a might lie about who
who were sliding the line to who makes
sure that we're double teaming this guy
up to that took that guy it's just hard
and defensive coordinators are very very
good understand the weaknesses of your
team and so they're saying okay well you
love the slide left we're gonna come
from the right or you love to slide
right and you man-to-man scheme we're
gonna come from the left and so to have
a young guy especially at this set of
positions that has the ability to get
the guys lined up to protect your
quarterback the right way
especially when you breeze gets back
protecting him is the most important
thing and it seemed of course five and
one yeah it makes sense you're winning
and the trenches
that's how you win football games
alright so I would about bought him I
would about my dad you don't never win
he'll never win and that's okay you'll
never win offensive player to you I
don't know that the analytics community
has really come full circle when we have
somebody like quittin Nelson last year
yeah where we can look at things like
hurries and sacks allowed and also like
some PFF grades and actually value a
tackle a guard or a center as highly as
we do a running back because well I you
trying to bring up their running back
don't bring up their running back the
running backs value doing a whole
different level like here's something
that I don't think people think about
we're talked about how the Cowboys lost
to the Jets
how do you lose to the gens I have a
firm belief that we we miss a little bit
the narrative of the four o'clock games
because what happens is is well the one
o'clock games are wrapping up and
everything's so exciting the injuries
come out certain actives come out for
the four o'clock game no one looks
that's right and so I bet if you talk to
a random fan did you know that the
Cowboys were missing both starting
offensive tackles last year I mean yeah
so for me it's like wow they didn't have
Lyle Collins or Tyron Smith and most of
them were questionable on Friday yeah
and so
I value offensive lineman more than I
value wide receivers like Golden Tate
can still give you a hundred yards
receiving
even if sterling Shepherds not there but
if you're missing your left tackle like
we saw what happened to the Bucks like
Jameis Winston was under attack because
they were missing two offensive linemen
against the Panthers look at me you can
even go back to looking at teams like
the Browns they got a bunch of studs on
the outside I mean they got Landry
Odell Beckham jr. and in both publicly
go yes Chubb can go and he's had a
couple good games in a row but if you
can't protect your quarterback you
whatever throw the football
I'll get the Rams you're gonna be in
trouble 80 yards passing yesterday and
I'll tell you what it's only gonna get
worse that's right fans their left guard
is now hurt Joseph Noteboom saw him on a
carton they were already down the right
guard in their center so you're telling
me an offense that's built around
play-action and running up the middle is
now Kanak to be able to do that like
we're gonna be in a weird time with the
Rams right now
well the Rams are sinking very very
quickly very quickly very very quick but
I have to tell you the big news of the
day so I'm gonna go in a little bit of
rant I'll go ahead okay let's go I have
now four weeks and you have heard me so
I need you to vouch for me I have said
that the Saints are gonna win the Super
or going to the Super Bowl okay yeah
right yes okay I believe their defense
the line with Cam Jordan the secondary
with Marshawn Lattimore is playing great
Teddy has kept them in the realm of
home-field advantage and I really
believe that this time offer breeze will
be insanely beneficial for the playoffs
giving his arm a break but something
happened yesterday that I think people
are laughing about and they're glossing
over and I don't think they need to take
it this lightly I think they need to
realize the Saints are destined to win
the Super Bowl yesterday Pope Francis
tweeted out hashtag Saints and because
of that the team's fleur-de-lis logo
popped up with it it said quote today we
give thanks to the Lord for our new
hashtag Saints they walked by faith and
now we invoke their intercession the
same speed the jaguars 13 to 6 just like
you did we laugh social medias hilarious
haha Twitter mm-hmm but that phrase they
walked by faith and now we invoke their
intercession
that's about asking saints and angels to
pray for us okay okay
in the Book of Revelations I went deep
on this Brian Wes how you buried deep it
says and the smoke of the incense of the
prayers of the Saints ascended up before
God from the hand of the angel this is
in reference to invoking intercessions
the hand of an angel the hand Brian
Westbrook which hand is seen as the
special place of honor in religion right
exactly
the right hand of God mm-hmm drew brees
is healing what right now oh wow there
is right hand right thumb they went
through the mean Minnesota miracle their
prayers were answered not New Orleans
they went through the Rams press a pass
interference no call their prayers were
answered not New Orleans it is all
building to this moment the Saints are
destined to win the Super Bowl
on the blessed right hand and the
prayers of the Saints and the angel that
is drew brees Westbrook there let their
backup quarterbacks last name is
fricking Bridgewater okay in the book of
Matthew about the bridge over troubled
waters what they are going through right
now right this is not about X's and O's
this is not about Jimmy's and Joe's
right this is about Oh
oh the Saints are Justin win Super Bowl
I'm just telling you right now I'd like
to say take whatever future about you
want the Angels are in the outfield
they're in the uniform they're in the
Superdome century needle I like the
Saints an awful lot I'll tell you this I
felt this yesterday
and I don't have Bible verses and the
Pope didn't mention these guys but
there's something about old reliable
Russell Wilson that I just love I love a
guy that I can say he reminds me of my
Ford f-350 I got a Benz yeah I got an
old-school drop-top Caprice humble
Briggs but that 350 run that old
reliable thing when it's snowing outside
I throw it in four-wheel drive when it's
hot I got a air-conditioned in there if
I need to carry some old pallets and hay
and all different types of stuff for the
horses I put in the back of that f-350
over libor us that's the guy you got to
depend on that's the guy that you know
at the end of the day he can run it he
can play action you to death if it's a
past that needs to be made some of the
best deep balls that we've seen over the
last 10 years
reliable Russ Seattle Seahawks tough
team to beat can I tell you why you
picked the one team that I think can can
bat sainthood it's because the Seahawks
have gone in the last few years from the
legion of boom to the legion of bloom
they went from everything is about
tenacity and anger and intimidation and
now it is about purity yes Russell
Wilson and Ciara
they did not consummate their marriage
until it happened smart man Tyler
Lockett came out recently and admitted
he's still a virgin
really I didn't hear that now yes there
are other wide receiver DK Metcalfe his
last name literally breaks and down into
a chance encounter with a child Metcalfe
a young did you see the video MEC did
you see the video of Pete Carroll taking
off his shirt I did see that
so in essence for this new young player
he had to go skin-to-skin contact
skin the skin like you would if that's a
born with the newborn that's right
they took Dwane Brown and Jadeveon
Clowney in the
freedom from the tyranny of the Texans a
franchise that did not that considered
its players to be inmates running the
asylum gave them a second life freed
them they have the Griffin brothers one
who was an inspiration to all with his
handicap and the way he's able to show
that anyone can overcome that's right
this is the one team that scares me
about the Saint should it should because
they are pure Dees and they are clean
but then also I'm a very afraid of the
Niners I just haven't come out with that
story like yeah coming on Wednesday and
I'll tell you what the Seahawks the
Niners know what their storyline is is
the one thing I will say about the
Seahawks the fact that they are going to
have to go through Richard Sherman is
what makes the NFC West so much fun the
fact that Richard Sherman is undefeated
on the Niners and he is the last real
representative Earl Thomas and by
everyone's accounts in terms of stats
and analytics yeah has taken a step back
right now
kam chancellor isn't playing anymore all
the other corners that were involved on
that team no longer irrelevant Richard
Sherman is and the fact that he is on
the Niners and he is playing the
underdog card and Russell Wilson and
Tyler Lockett and the Legion of Blume
are now going to be battling it out is
so phenomenal it's gonna be great well I
think this I love the 49ers I love with
John Lynch is done
I mean he's built a quality quality
defense that that's where y'all start
set it starts on the defensive line and
and when you watch those guys in the
secondary yes they're nasty I don't know
any of their names all they do is their
physical Jimmy Ward I know the guys
Nathan know you think when you talk
about some of the best guys in the
country and then the end the NF but on
the tops you don't mention those guys
but they fly around there they're
defensive coordinators the hypest guy
that I've ever seen before
yes but Robert Solow one thing that I
have to cost you about the 49ers Tampa
Bay average oh yeah Cincinnati below
average Pittsburgh I think they're
coming on but week three yeah there's
average team Cleveland average at best
and then the Rams
absolutely as far as tesco apps they
still are at that point where they
have been tested when they get into the
meat of that NFC West schedules we'll
see about this 249 and and I'll say I'm
saying that we're thinking that there'll
be second best team in that division
I want it before we give all the credit
to John Lynch for building a team
because we do that a lot with GM's what
I give credit to John Lynch for is by
apparently him and he listens to Kyle a
lot sure about the types of players he
wants absolutely should we look at Dan
Quinn right now and we laugh right the
Atlanta Falcons are absolutely abysmal
and what's funny is is we were giving
Dan Quinn all this praise for in that 13
and 3 season when they ran when they
went all the way led by Kyle Shannon's
offense the entire time we gave Dan
Quinn the credit because in the
preseason they did military workouts
together and he got them as a team but
the reason that team was great much like
the Chiefs were so nasty last year was
when you have an offense that puts
pressure on the defense your secondary
doesn't even really need to be that
great but you need to have really good
pass rushers that falcons team was able
to employ Vic Beasley and a few other
guys that are no longer on the team to
get after the quarterback this Niners
team it's really their detriment became
their strength
oh you drafted Eric Armstead hasn't
really worked out your running defense
still sucks oh you drafted to forest
Buckner hasn't worked out you can't get
up to the quarterback all you drafted
Salomon Thomas you could have had
Patrick mahomes orangish Shawn Watson oh
you draft nick beau so you've drafted
defensive linemen four years in a row
but now when I watch the games
everyone goes they got four first
rounders on the offensive line you talk
[ __ ] about them for four years and now
we're going wow this is an incredible
assortment of talent right yeah because
they they realize we can load up now we
only have to bring four they go and they
get quan alexander for the Bucs so they
have speed at linebacker
and they have smart defensive backs that
are all safety hybrids Richard Sherman's
a safety hybrid Jimmy Ward's a safety
hybrid like a killer Weatherspoon's
still hurt my physical and will come up
and tackle you ball ha and I and I think
also George kid all had a great quote
after the game yesterday after they held
the
to seven points in Jared Goff to under
90 yards passing it kind of makes sense
why Jimmy Garoppolo threw five
interceptions that one practice when
everybody killed him this offseason Oh
Jimmy Grabbe was not great if your five
interceptions into practice if we knew
he was going up against this defense we
go damn the Niners are a really good
defense but instead let's jump on how
average Jimmy has played the one thing
I'd say is that's my one pump up for the
Niners is all those things are very true
but I don't think we've seen Jimmy
Garoppolo at like 18 on capacity still
hasn't he still making bad throws and
and and I think George Kittles the best
hated in the NFL like I'm pretty
confident about it at this point he's
played the best in the NFL he just he
hits a gear where I think he's don't
want to hit him and that's so rare to be
that much more physical than ever he's a
psychopath it's it's amazing to see the
way that cow has schemed up certain
things with the run game with keeping a
defense off balance beam and you know so
many people want to make the NFL
complicated at some point it comes down
to this building in the trenches we
talked about the defense and obviously
the office and we're going to talk about
but if you can run the ball when they
think you're passing you're gonna be
successful if you could pass the ball
when they think you're running yes you
could be successful if you have the
defense guessing and thinking about what
you have going on like warren sharp you
could be very sick this game is actually
pretty simple now how you do it in with
the formations and a personnel it
certainly can change up but this game
can be really really simple cow shearing
the hand that has just done a great job
they run the doggone football they
averaged 180 yards on the ground every
single game and it never seems like
they're forcing it no another George
Kittel quote apparently earlier this
year against the Browns Monday Night
Football
apparently Kittel they're out like 24
points goes up to Kyle and goes stop
passing the ball we're taking their soul
with the run so this is a team that
likes to run and you want one more
compliment for Kyle Shanahan as I as I
made an excuse for the Cowboys earlier
Cowboys were down two offensive linemen
wow that sucks the Rams were down their
interior offensive linemen think wow
that sucks the Niners are down both
tackles and their fullback and it wasn't
an issue
there are two coaches in this league
that you can take away their left and
their right and they'll headbutt you and
knock you out and that is Bill Belichick
and Kyle Shanahan well you can take away
anybody from them and they will figure
out a way to beat you just named three
key positions to a run game and their
rules delay in a row all over the ranch
still the second-best running team in
the NFL me that's that speaks to your
attitude to your coaching your
philosophies it also helps your defense
a lot oh no time of possession oh just
sit over to chanc chill out and we'll
run the ball down the throat and there
is a thing and I'm glad you're I'm glad
you brought it up because there's a
point in the game when you're beating
somebody up when I'm beating the man up
that he gives you a look that says you
know what I don't want no more of that
yeah and that's the time where you say
we go back to the huddle you say just
keep doing this the dunes yesterday like
AP was running like this is my return
that's right and I'm telling you by the
third quarter y'all go back and watch
that he just starts jumping into me more
and they're moving out of the way I
don't want to play just didn't because
he's a little bit well sometimes you
talk about it about defensive guys
making business decisions like hey man I
was just want to play next week I'm here
for my check I want to make sure my
check is there or Monday I don't want to
be in the training room I'm gonna go out
there and play some football but I don't
want to play it a physical nasty game I
just want to play a game where I can
jump on your back and tackle you down I
don't want you to run through me the
49ers play a physical NASA career and
football and they don't have big running
backs
these guys are small too quick they're
shifty freitas get in and out I mean
they're made I mean what they're doing
is amazing I love what Kyle Shanahan has
done but you know you know what you
don't want to give all the credit to
John Lynch but I love anytime first I
just love the fact that the the GM and
the coach are one together saying okay
these are guys we need it's been like
that they have had some tough times of
course it has I think it's really
interesting too because if you think
about it the original plan for Kyle and
San Francisco wants to get Kurt cousins
that was the play I'm glad he didn't do
that I'm glad I'm just glad he didn't
good cousins are so interesting
Kirk Cousins is a obviously he had a
great game against the Eagles yesterday
yeah throw the ball
I mean there's a lot of different things
and now and I like these biking team
probably I don't have spend too much of
incur cousins so let's do the final
dolphin 10 let's do that and then we'll
probably get to it later to get them
finally into the tent there's a certain
quarterback that let go believes is
deserving of more love in the MVP race
it's elementary my dear how this young
passer has been fighting like a tiger
all year don't mess with him or the
state he plays it who is left no talking
about invest and find out
Skye's team is four and two he has two
dynamic wide receivers that are great
but occasionally have drops he's thrown
for the longest air yard completion in
the NFL and has a quarterback rating
third best in the NFL are you investing
so the team is born - yeah hit the
longest area are being the longest
areare complete my investing on what the
quarterback the quarterback to be more
discussed in the MVP race - really good
receivers that occasionally drop and the
third-best cube quarterback rating in
the NFL yeah yeah why not I think it is
Lamar Jackson mmm it's Kurt cousins like
I if you listened I had in bur inputted
my my dear Watson and the Tigers I was
like I want him to think it's the Shawn
Watson yeah yeah no it's Kurt cousins
yeah you just bought some [ __ ] now
you're gonna with Kurt I'm glad that you
brought that up because I'm gonna tell
you this this is why I actually and I
don't love Curtis oh this is why I
actually like the Vikings oh I love
their defensive spin mode I love their
defense I love what they do defensively
they're nasty they're big they're two
nations up front they got some
linebackers they can move around and run
bar and Kendricks in the secondary their
physical - nasty right so I like their
defense offensively they run the
football so if you want to in they're
one of the few teams and I think San
Francisco does it too they employ two
tight ends and a fullback yes and
there's not a lot of teams in the league
I even have a fullback on the roster
they put a fullback back there and a
tight end and they say okay you play
base defense three linebackers in four
defensive linemen and now that means
your safeties and your quarterbacks are
all by themselves as three three guys in
the back that's it and so you bring the
safety down to try to stop the run game
with the tight end and the fullback yes
and now you got one-on-one on the
outside this is why I think this team
has the makings of being a really good
offensive to me you already see the run
game if Kirk Cousins can kind of play
halfway decent soldiers
was on the outside this is a very good
football team if he can do that my
counter will be this you look at
everyone's talking about how great Kirk
Cousins is at home I got asked on the
radio today in Toronto if they were to
somehow get a home playoff game would
Curt kill it because he's done so while
I said the only thing I would say is we
know very well the Eagles past defense
[ __ ] sucks yes and so to hang up 38
on them we've seen a lot of quarterbacks
dice them out this year no doubt about
it the other team where Kirk played
really well against Atlanta who I
believe is the worst past defense the
NFL so and and he did do really well
against the Oakland Raiders but a lot of
that was Dalvin cook my only thing will
be is I think you look at who they've
lost to and those are the teams that can
beat them Green Bay and Chicago two
teams with very good defensive lines
that don't need to add extra guys to the
box because that's my issue with
Minnesota is if you have a really good
front for like the Niners do really good
contender Packers and bears in their own
division the Lions would have a really
good front for then I can put two on
Diggs because like you just said if
you're going to tight end one running
back you only got one guy ice right and
so if I can double Diggs and the only
dude I'm worried about is Irv Smith I
got you right where I need you the
question is is can they stop Dalvin with
the front four two teams have done it
both have a good front for next up at
Detroit it's gonna be a [ __ ] tough
there's gonna be a tough game like I'm
already telling you I'm probably leading
the Lions tip I think I think the
Packers aren't necessarily built I'm
sorry I don't think the Packers are
built to handle this type of run game
and I know they are they beat a - yeah
yeah but I just think that physically in
Minnesota you're saying yeah I just
think physically wise that they won't be
able to stand up to it consistently and
I think that I think the bike is one the
next time they play the Packers mmm it
will be interesting but that's that's
been my note about the Vikings is
they're very matchup dependent and their
home away splits are very tough because
like their one road game right now is
the Giants and it's 28 to 10 but that
score is very misleading that's right
Shermer I think got fined after the game
for complaining about the officials
surprise surprise
but
the Giants had a number of trips to the
red zone where they just didn't cash in
but you know this the next road trip for
the for the Vikings at the Lions I think
will be very tough home against
Washington we should see them bounce
back right away and have another big day
or the P but then it's at Kansas City
and that's like well I'll say this they
should be able to run all over here this
should be a great opportunity to do
almost the same thing that happened to
Kansas City this this past weekend be
able to run the ball down their throat
consume a bunch of the clock and then
make them try to play catch-up because
they have started slow in a bunch of
games so I eyed Joe King Lee talked
about Kirk Cousins in the MVP race I do
not believe he should be an MVP chase I
just wanted you to buy Kirk Cousins we
just you did this is not a well I what I
like the way it's not read if he could
play on this podcast your Kirk Cousins
biggest fan you bought them I don't have
them anymore we look good the only as
good as your last game he looked good
yesterday the four names that I'm
hearing in the MVP which is very funny
to me because people really don't care
about the MVP or they just like the
debate during the year and then what
happens they're like who cares about
them right Russell Wilson yes
deshaun Watson has now thrown himself
free you hat-trick mahomes Christian
McCaffrey those are the four that I keep
hearing
I keep hearing people sitting again we
don't know what happened on Monday Night
Football Aaron Rodgers does big
absolutely get there I'm throwing Devin
McCourty in there just because I think
someone from this Patriots defense needs
to be representative especially the last
two weeks the last three weeks bills
Washington and Giants the offense has
been slow and and to a crawl at points
for the Patriots and this defense has
been the offense blocked punts
interceptions fumble recoveries but is
there any one I'm missing or of the the
ones I mentioned is there when you feel
strongest about you already went on your
roster I love roasted racing I think
when I be rushed to but I think the
Shaun Watson is doing some some
interesting things and he has some good
talent on the outside as well and so he
has the ability to throw the ball he has
ability to run around it I think as we
see this thing evolve the league these
let this next year or two we'll see
quarterbacks being able to run the ball
we're not gonna be getting back to the
the pocket passer days yeah what you're
saying hey this guy's sick
five he's gonna stand in the pocket and
throw the ball the defense is just too
athletic now it's it takes your offense
back in the other direction
I love deshaun Watson Watson he has
ability to throw every pass in a brief
he can get outside of the pocket
scramble to make some moves out there
run the football almost as good as Lamar
Jackson yeah but this team has to
consistently I'm not gay okay Lamar just
ran for a hundred that's it almost as
good
almost as good I mean he can run almost
as good as Tyler he's a good I let me
just tell you right now if you don't buy
[ __ ] stocking calimary well I'll tell
you this Kyler back - come on - the
psychic Kyler I just love Kyler scouted
Lamar they don't like it in this we're
because I don't think you know I love
Lamar yeah I don't even want Lamar in
the same conversation because I believe
that Kyler is the next Russell Wilson
that's how strong I believe in Kyler
Connors really really I don't think he's
as big and could handle the hits right
now he needs to put a lot more weight
but I'm just telling you when I watch
Kyler it is magnificent our magnificent
yes great arm - accuracy watch our
talent that's fine that's outside of the
pocket balls accurate good and he needs
to run and he gets in he can run oh I
didn't realize he was the worst wide
receivers of all of the people that were
mentioning the worst offensive line of
all the people that were mentioning the
coach with the least amount of seasoning
and every time I turn him on he's the
reason they're in the game yeah it's
let's young Russell Wilson it's amazing
he's electric he gets that offense going
his speed is a different level decisive
different me because he made a move
yesterday and ran a ball you're like
whoa whoa whoa he loved me he looked
fast like a wide receiver type of fast
i I don't want him taking any more any
more hits alright so you're talking
about deshaun Watson yeah I'd like to
Shawn Watson I think he should be in the
conversation of course he is
I'm also too trying to think of who else
my home is in the conversation in the
conversation
yeah and then we've talked about
McCaffrey before McCaffrey it has to be
in the conversation if if he could keep
this up and get close to 25 26 hundred
yards you have to put them in there
especially their team continues to win
in Berhad these notes it is pretty crazy
that McCaffrey had a down year in terms
of fantasy and he still scored two
touchdowns
yeah can you name the last three running
backs to win and the
P when you hear them you're gonna go ah
agent Peterson one it one yeah did you
did you Marlow which wouldn't nvp he did
not he did not one of them is a Hall of
Famer and the other one Marshall Faulk
nope
Marshall Faulk never won the MVP it
wasn't in the last three was him we said
the last three years yeah last three
running backs win MVP okay um one of
them is known by his initials that LT
yes LaDainian okay and then the other
one had a year where he had so many
touchdowns that it was disgusting and he
played for the same team that Russell's
on now Omar Sean Sean Alexander yeah I
remember Madden for that yeah yeah I
remember other little notes nothing
after that either which is kind of crazy
yeah that happened Larry Johnson didn't
do a lot of try would be concerned if
I'm this that the Panthers for the same
thing I'm not
I absolutely would be that you burn this
young kid out are you are you kidding
man is an interesting discussion I mean
he is playing more a higher percentage
of snaps than any running because great
almost all the snaps yes you can't
afford to take them off the field you're
almost in a situation and this is our
this is a credit to him actually yeah
and if you're the coaching staff you're
saying how do I take my best player off
the field when you watch the kid play
you have to think about well if it's a
passing play we have to have our best
receiver on the field if there's a
running play we have to have our best
runner on the field and guess what if we
have to block he steps up in blocked we
never want the kid off the field the
concern for me is that when you have a
guy this talented will you burn him out
too early in the career and running
backs career are already shortened of
course he's trained he's in shape he
looks bigger yeah I'm concerned that
they wear him out I know you should you
should be too what do they do because he
is the ultimate Jackman he's the only
reason one of the big reason that the
rid their will he is the reason the
d-line just some other notes
mahomes 14 touchdowns one interception
this year the only interception was that
awful call that they had where he
definitely should have gotten it from
pass interference little note about
Watson second fastest to 7,500
cards behind only Kurt Warner which was
like an historic pace when he did it
McCourt knee again accordion for picks
five passes defended the Patriots
defense has scored five touchdowns 35
points opposing offenses have only
scored 27 points that's [ __ ] cream
they haven't played anybody either
of course but Wilson this is what's
crazy
his passer rating is a hundred and
twenty four point seven that's twelve
point eight points higher than the
Holmes the difference between him and
mahomes is the same as between second
and tenth place he has opened the season
with six straight games over a hundred
passer rating only two quarterbacks have
ever opened with seven straight Brady
and Rodgers and they both went on to win
MVP those years 14 touchdowns most
important stat this is Russell's arrow
zero interceptions yeah that's the most
important stat I mean listen we can we
could talk about all the QB R and
touchdown stuff like that but if you
don't turn the ball over
then you're gonna win a bunch of game
let me take it to another point how many
touchdowns did he have 14 so 14 and
nothing this is not a Drew Brees type of
passing out no it's not this is not a
get this is not a McCaffrey offense this
is this is this is Jaron brown yeah and
DK Metcalfe and the throws that are
being made he had a throw to Jaron brown
I don't know why I'm saying it like that
yesterday where he was getting destroyed
and threw it off his back for foot
touchdown yeah the touchdown last
Thursday to Tyler Lockett throwing it
running left crossbody lob to the only
point where it could be caught six point
three percent chance that that ball was
gonna be completed nice NextGen's like
this drop that was really good to the
next level it's not it's not what we've
seen where it's either you're really
safe and you don't turn the ball over no
he is has all the risk on him and he's
throwing crazy balls and he still hasn't
thrown a pick dropping dimes I mean it's
been amazing to watch but it also shows
you how much it professionally is
because he was questioned early on
especially by some of his teammates yes
how he's carried himself how he's led
this team and I think a lot of people
would say going into the season he
didn't have a bunch of talent around him
but he's developing talent he
making guys look better he isn't he's
literally they talk about a lot now he's
the elevator he's making guys around him
better for years on this podcast we
talked about how Russell Wilson's the
most underrated quarterback in the NFL
he has the most on his back but the
problem was with all those defensive
stars he never got the credit because it
was always Richard Sherman's team yeah
he was overshadowed this year the
Seahawks have allowed 2026
33 29 and 28 not including the Arizona
game and they won four of those five
games but the point is not the defense
and that's what their defense allowed
they put up more obviously because they
won but it's he's had to do it and he's
done it's been incredibly well this is
why I like the Seahawks because the
team's
you just mentioned it the team's are
scoring a bunch of points on them but
they they're winning these close games
they got a comeback in the fourth
quarter and score a touchdown they need
to feel go and we think about it
they beat Cincinnati by went therefore
and won right now in one score game I
mean they're mean none of these teams
they've beat the only team that they've
beat by more than seven points is
Arizona all the other teams all the
other games are one point two points
it's a little scary
it's it is scary but it also shows you
that we are resilient we're working hard
we know how to work together and we know
how to win the close games so when you
get to the playoffs and you're down by
one and you need to go game when he
score reliable Russ he is reliable Russ
man when I have 350 when I go to work I
need to think dawg I need my f-350 mm-hm
I need three things my f-350 a cup of
coffee and Russell wills also Wilson
when I go to work there's nothing more
reliable than a Russ in arrest hey he's
the man mr. Wilson alright let's break
down every tea every division and figure
out who is the best team in every
division I think a lot of times it comes
down to two teams and a quick little
discussion some we can move on quickly
some I want to sit in a little bit
longer because I think we're gonna
disagree and I'm making you a promise
right now that if we agree I am gonna
play devil's advocate okay and I look I
will argue with you just to argue with
you because it's gonna be fun cuz you'd
like to do that that's
favorite pastime it's literally what our
job is yeah let's do it
we're literally paid to argue about
things that don't matter that's right
that's right I do that all the time at
home with the kids so that's not healthy
yeah well my kids they don't seem to
understand what I'm trying to get him
I'm not I'm not older than two I wonder
what you're like listen
rooks only go up and to the side well
this is what I told my son I say come
here come here
okay okay he's walking away the other
way he has no intention or listening to
me I don't sidenote parenting is hard I
know I'm trying to think of what I would
do I want to give you I think that'd be
actually a fun segment if I gave you
parenting advice having never had kids
it would be funny not fun funny yeah
first thing I would do is I would take a
candy that you like anything a sick Nick
like a Snickers yeah and I would eat it
and then I would take the empty wrapper
and I go look what I got for you a
little bribry a bribe and then he would
come over and I'd be like psyche dreams
aren't real now listen to me if you want
to survive Ribery
is a real a true parents tactic one of
the best tactics you can never use
bribery okay bribery and fear to to just
take that for it sounds like great
parenting that's a very in fear all
right first division AFC East Patriots
are six no bills are four and one who is
the better team be honest oh no no no I
think I think the Patriots because of
Bill Belichick yes so--but I can't I
think in our guy I will say that I think
the bills they're up and coming they
still not ready yet to overcome the
Patriots so yeah that's it that's an
easy one but I don't feel strongly about
the Patriots at all so here's here's the
argument that I that you and I want to
make oh if I was good to say the bells I
go well the Patriots have played the
third easiest schedule right of course
guess what the Bills have played the
fourth easy schedule so it's not like
they haven't played as murders and
murderers row the only thing I will say
and I know that rap sheet came out and
said it's not a major injury if Josh
Gordon is hurt I already have questions
about this offense and that would raise
it to a very alarming level because I
just don't who don't know who the wide
receiver is that's gonna win 50/50 balls
is for they don't have one and that's
why they went out and probably just they
recited Watson but
I think Sony Michele's a lot better than
people say is I think Rex Burkhead and
James White are great players that give
like multiplicity to the offense I don't
see the tight ends Julian Edelman is
still great but if Josh Gordon is hurt
and it's bigger than they think it is I
am a little worried here's the truth
about the Patriots they're on a
different level coaching wise they're
not gonna make a bunch of mistakes but
at some point attrition has to happen to
every single team I mean you lose
offensive lineman
well they have they've lost love that
they haven't played anybody yet that's
the thing they haven't played anybody
and they've lost but what happens when
they play somebody that can that can
take advantage of these missing things
now let's play a dimensions a team on
the Patriots schedule and Westbrook says
if it's scary or not next up the Jets
yes the game is scary because I'll tell
you this just having Sam contracts
coming off ten days rest to face the
Jets in New York I'm and Arnold's
healthy
Robbie Anderson's ready to roll prepared
to say that the Jets will win but it'll
be interesting because I think the Jets
have a pretty decent defense and I think
that Sam d'Arnaud is a live arm he has a
good wheels and he'll make it
interesting he'll make the lease the the
Patriots defense worked just a little
bit I'm gonna point your attention to
when we're gonna because if you look
it's at the Jets it's home against
Cleveland and it's at Baltimore in my
opinion all three of those teams have
flaws that Belichick is gonna be able to
absolutely to figure out and be fine
yeah but after the break is when it gets
interesting after the bye week they play
at the Eagles Eagles also coming off a
bye week gonna be a desperate team home
against the Cowboys yeah at the Texans
home against the Chiefs that is the
four-game stretch where if it's if it's
Patriots Super Bowl it's for know it's
three and one
yeah if it's oh this could get really
interesting it's two into one and three
I just so you know we'll never on this
podcast or any form of media ever call
that this is the end of the Patriots the
Patriots could lose the next three weeks
heading into the button and I'm telling
you that I will still pick the Patriots
to win the Super Bowl okay I am NOT
doing it I am NOT saying
are done until either Brady or Belichick
retires until that happens everybody is
playing for second place and I'm being
sincere I don't care if mahomes they
somehow get Aaron Donald on their team I
don't care if deshaun Watson grows a
third arm and is allowed to throw two
touchdowns at one time and they both
count I would be special until the
Patriots until Brady or Belichick are
removed
I will pick them to win every Super Bowl
because that's what they [ __ ] do and
I really like there's no team in the NFL
right now like other than the Saints
because they're guided by the Lord that
I think has a chance I'll tell you this
and I might have agreed with you a
couple weeks ago I think the Patriots
are flawed in a way I think offensively
because they believe they're flawed too
and I know they're saving graces saving
Jesus was not I'm getting no he wasn't
no he wasn't he was perfect I didn't
know one person that was I just had your
own Kippur yeah I got a tone for that
later got to figure that out man I'll
say anyway there's a thing the offense
is flawed I mean just look at the bills
gang their office look terrible
I understand look terrible I understand
what if it's what if there's a team that
gets a special teams kickoff return or
something crazy a pump return they're
able to score in that in their defense
the Patriots defense is not involved
with it at some point I just think that
their offense is gonna have to score 35
points movie not 35 points let's say 30
points and I don't know that they're
prepared to do that I don't know that
they can consistently run the football
with that offensive line I don't know
that they can consistently protect Tom
Brady with that offensive line and who
are the weapons that you go to on 3rd
and 5 didn't he win a Super Bowl with
rachet yes he did and David I was long
ago seconds you guys as long as I don't
know I don't remember I remember
just long ago I know that you could get
now he wasn't I think they had Troy
Brown and those guys anyway I'm just
saying man that Brady wasn't the Jacoby
Meyer can look like an all-star yeah
gunner all Chesky and after the game
where a wife-beater throwing a Lipper
yeah and talk about you know Bubba Gump
shrimp and they'll still win there is
nothing that can happen they are going
to the Super Bowl I don't care I don't
know that I'll make that bet right now
you re Omiya well you're
a dollar I do not you literally owe me a
dollar you know the only memory I owe
you a dollar but we'll be even because
this other we don't know we don't know
he's definitely gonna Detroit if he
traded the traders voice no no no no no
three knows if no gets traded no that
was no say if we didn't put it if one
day you said that he's going to Detroit
is what you sought the you to but I'll
have little ones to lit up
that's me just making up make up your
own bed we went to you I will bet you
one money I need odds I need I'm gonna
give only five to one us a dollar so if
I win you owe me five if you win I owe
you a dollar I am gonna take the
Patriots to represent the AFC in the
Super Bowl
oh no I'm down why would I give you $5
you get every other team in the AFC No
here's the questions you're getting
you're getting 15 teams well you're
talking about the best team and
defending champions what are you talking
about their flaws there's there's
sixteen oh so there are there they are
flawed absolutely they're flawed and you
you agree with that yeah like I'm giving
you you do you agree with that that
there was a Vegas odds Ingeborg well I
mean you never mind the Patriots are two
to three to go Super Bowl alright so
they're they're a really big favorite
Vegas agrees with me but you think that
flood they are flawed all right so I'll
do one dollar Patriots go to the Super
Bowl for the AC you get every other team
in this is October 14th bet and I want
my money too
well you'll get it in February the
pictures are flying can you admit that
though they are of course can you also
admit that picking any other team is
dumb
no and now then I'll tell you why
because on Sundays when you get a
quarterback like the marquee the
Thursday no Joan all I'm saying is that
when you see the development of Watson
and in Jackson and quarterbacks like
that any you know I just think that
having a running quarterback that can
get to the heirs it changes the changes
that the diet by the dynamic of the
defense
it moves things around and Bill
Belichick can he can plan for guys in
the pocket or he could plan for things
that go exactly right you can't plan for
these guys moving
and he's gonna have to face a couple
guys in that conference my home's
included that certainly can do that
improvise that can do all those special
things that you can't plan for
defensively well he went to know against
mahomes last year I was time playing you
know you got to figure it out the thing
is is in all time they should have lost
that game in a long time I don't believe
that we've ever seen a coach with more
control or the outcome of a game than
the New England Patriots mhm I agree
with that so I love to Shawn Watson and
I love my homes and they can put up
thirty five but the Patriots are going
to find a way to manufacture 36 I don't
think they can they have to have they've
done all those things with crunk oh then
they you would sort of run a game what
the running game does not is not the
same if you don't have Gronk on the edge
blocking it's a different game
oh then Gronk opens up things for
Edelman oh and every now and then Josh
Gordon would go down to catch their
signature server rated right now I
didn't say that the over I know I was
asking no no this is what I think I
think that they are flawed football team
they're still very good don't get me
wrong there's no very good I just think
they're flawed yeah and I think that's
gonna be their undoing
interesting offensive like we talked we
just kept it is talking about it or win
in the trenches yeah Tom Brady's getting
beat up a bunch sure Isaiah when is
gonna come back a little bit at some
point I am so happy I'm on the dollar
checks side why are you on their side
because you're like Luke Skywalker
you're like clearly if the federation
bands together we have a chance no I'm
like that I have the Darth Lord on my
side really that can control everything
yeah am I so confident Bill Belichick
well no why are you so confident in
April have you seen what they played
they played nobody that's fine what's
your high school team thing Abington
friends yeah they played Abington
Friends kangaroos they don't have a
football team I invented how did you go
to a high school without football
I invented the flag football program
with my buddy Dan LuPone there really
yeah we built it is it exists what like
look like a really good program on the
algae Crumpler flag football all right
AFC North we'll go a little bit quicker
here I really thought was gonna be quick
who is the best team in the NFC North
the right
and okay clearly you argue the Ravens
and I will argue the Steelers I think
the Steelers are the second best thing
well yeah I didn't ask that well I'll
tell you why I think the Ravens but I
think they I think their defense is is
pretty good they'll be no get even
better
I think the offense continues to be run
dominant you can't is hard to control
the clock when you have a team that's
gonna run the ball as well as they do
with Ingram as well as the quarterback I
think Lamar Jackson will continue to
improve
I like Mark Andrews now that he's
completely healthy and I think at some
point Browns gonna make some sense with
the deep ball so the argument that I
would make if I was trying the Raiders
will win all the special teams wars they
win all specialty hats definitely gonna
happen that have I agree if I had to
make an argument for the Steelers I
would have picked the Ravens but if I
had to argue for the Steelers Baltimore
has faced the easiest schedule the NFL
mm-hmm Pittsburgh has faced the fourth
toughest Pittsburgh took Baltimore to
overtime and in that game their starting
quarterback got tragically concussed
their third stringer came in with no
preparation and they still almost won
the game had the ball in overtime to win
Pittsburgh's defense is much better than
the Baltimore Ravens defense their fifth
and sacks per pass attempt we saw it
against Philip Rivers they can get after
the quarterback and Baltimore's defense
absolutely stinks
I just look at the Ravens right now and
I would pick them to be better because
even the game they lost Baltimore out
getting the Steelers laying yard stay
committed more turnovers and they had
the ball for 14 more minutes than the
Steelers but I would put you the reason
why the Ravens are better but yes but
know that that's the read no that's the
reason I I believe the Ravens are better
yeah but if I'm playing devil's advocate
that's how I would argue for the skin
that can the Steelers win on the road
that's going to be the big question can
they win in a row right now they're one
in two in the road King game is waiting
at the Chargers is not really around now
and that's not a robe that was a home
game for them so can they go on the road
in a hostile environment and win that's
the bit course that's the test of young
quarterbacks these second thirst ring
quarterbacks
can't you win on a roll I think what you
said is really the test is we've now
seen in their last two games the
strategy is let's feature James Conner a
lot get on the ball in short areas let
let's do some screens we'll do some
pulling guards
and occasional shots who is the bet who
is the next team that is gonna face this
team that's gonna go we're gonna double
James wherever he goes
beat me with juju well juju had one
catch last night yes seven yards
something that's just nothing that's not
enough I mean I just think that when you
have a one-dimensional team it's gonna
be much easier to stop because that's
especially with the backup quarterback
you're saying hey we're just gonna put
eight men in the box and if you beat us
throwing over the top that's what you
just did this it looks gonna be tricky
the AFC South mmm who's the best team I
I think the Texas are the best but I
something about the Colts I really
really like okay so who's your official
pick I'm gonna go I'm gonna go Colts Wow
all right again I like the Texans I'm
still concerned about their ability to
win the big game protect the quarterback
but Bree said there's something about
Jacoby percent that I actually like I
think Marlin Mac has the run game goes
they've done a much better job offensive
line wise winning in trenches they they
they kind of check off that box there
and I like their defense I think their
defense has some dog to it I think they
get after it a little bit and I think
Jacoby percent is gonna make the right
throw he's not gonna be throwing the
ball all over the place it's not gonna
be you're not gonna make a bunch of
mistakes he's gonna make the right throw
at the right time and I think that that
that's just as important as throwing the
interception
I mean it's throwing a touchdown not
throwing the interception not throwing
the the ball into triple coverage but
throwing the ball away how about you
just do that and there are some times
when I'm watching this Texans team where
I'm like you know what they're gonna get
this kid deshaun Watson killed bang
their the argument for the Texans
they're four and two so they already
have the better record they do I I think
that they have multiple guys on their
team that are more talented than anybody
on the Colts absolutely I believe that
they might have the best trio in terms
of quarterback wide receiver wide
receiver in the league it's it's close
in terms of their caliber Watson is a
true MVP caliber player know where the
Texans many people go the Colts can run
the ball control time of possession
the Texans actually have a better time
of possession than the Colts right now
they are top ten
in pass and rush the Texans are the
Colts our 27th in pass what's very
beautiful about this little battle is
they play next week yes and so we're
gonna see who is that game is the flow
it is gonna be in Indianapolis okay I
believe I'll take Andy on that let me
know when to tell me I listen I like the
Texans I mean they you made all the good
points and I think you're absolutely
right they have a bunch of talent
especially outside
it's almost speed they got some guys
that can run full-speed he can run and
he dropped three touchdowns yeah by the
way Hopkins is gonna fantasy - yeah he's
gonna catch every ball in his area and
Deshawn continues to make things it
keeps things alive the one thing that
really scares me if you're going for the
Texans is starting tackle Titus Howard
is gonna miss a few weeks at the MCL
spring got hurt Watson is already one of
the most sacked quarterbacks in the
sport and that is why if I really had to
pick I I would lean towards the Colts
because while I believe that the Texans
have the better quarterback
I believe the Colts have the better
coach and I believe they have the better
offensive line I love Frank Reich now I
tell you I think that their ad matter
they're a more a more well constructed
football team but well just Shaun hat
DeSean is a kind of guy that can just
overcome anything Bill O'Brien that's a
problem for the Texans that's a big
problem I think Frank Wright schemes how
coaches him and run circle around him
we're gonna find out at all times
yeah Talent the Texans have more talent
that's the biggest thing AFC West who's
the best team I think the Chiefs are the
best team all right I have big concerns
about the Chiefs here's a big concern if
you can't run the football consistently
orden it's not willing to they can run
it
they gave LeSean McCoy their leading
rusher eight carries yesterday huh this
is one that one of my beliefs in sports
is that when you have a dominant player
like mahomes is dominant you depend on
him so much that you don't develop
everything around him right and so Andy
Reed understands what he has in his
quarterback it's so way so good he can
win the game just with his arm and legs
and don't behind the back pass all those
different things but
you neglect the run game you forget
about that you forget about your defense
that you got a play too just a little
bit you can't leave them on the foil for
40 minutes now I don't think Oakland is
gonna ever get good enough to beat them
and overcome them in that AFC West
however I think unfortunately they're in
a position where that defense is gonna
let them down a bunch they can't stop
the run if you can't stop the run you're
gonna have problems in the NFL oh and
guess what happens after you can't stop
the run now you dedicate eight people to
try to stop the run if you get passed
over top of your head and so they got
some fundamental issues especially if my
homes is not special every single game
that's gonna be a problem for me the two
biggest issues for the Chiefs are my
home is under more pressure than he's
ever been those the offensive line yeah
and they can't stop the run yeah but the
thing is is for Chiefs fans both of
those things will be fixed soon they're
starting left tackle Eric Fisher has not
played in a game all year he'll be back
soon
their best defensive lineman who I
believe is playing better than Fletcher
Cox right now Chris Jones did not play
yesterday against taxies disease and
this is another example of people
looking at a game and going the Chiefs
can't stop anybody you go okay so Chris
Jones missed the second half of their
first loss and then all of their second
loss and he was a top five sack guy
Vienna felt a defensive tackle position
last year so they will both be getting
better but if I had to make an argument
for the Raiders this is where I would go
Kansas City's run defense is indeed 30th
yeah Oakland's is top ten yeah can open
football too and they're getting Gabe
Jackson back who I keep talking about is
gonna help the pounding Kansas City is
last in first downs al are allowed per
game and what's wild is they're actually
good at third down defense which means
teams aren't even having to get to third
down to beat the Chiefs Kansas City is
30th in time of possession right now
they cannot stay on the field you know
what the Raiders are eighth so the
Raiders in a weird way because of how
big their offensive line is and as I
said last week how big their defensive
line is is going to be able to get after
the quarterback without bringing
Blitzers and block Kansas
they're much better in the redzone than
the Chiefs and if you had to be honest I
know Kansas City beat the Raiders 28 to
10 right they did not score a point in
three quarters of that game zero early
2800 that's my argument if I'm trying to
say how the Raiders can be a better team
than the Chiefs it would have to be an
app they would have to turn into the
Colts which I don't see happening but
Derek Carr has been protecting the ball
better than anybody
Gruden finally has his back and Josh
Jacobs yes and they have maybe a defense
to contend with Kansas City but I would
still take the cheese oh yeah I still
would take the cheese but when you talk
to me you think about it a new team that
can control the clock yeah they're top
ten just for some crazy reason my
homeless throws an interception crazy
they lose period that's it it's just
that simple they have to be better
defensively they'll lose every game
because of the defense if my homes is
not spent by one note first Steve
spagnolo defensive coordinator I love
Spags I love him here's my thing I never
liked Gunther Cunningham no but one
thing he did was he blitzed like a
madman to try and get the ball back yeah
now sometimes it would lead to a long
touchdown but sometimes it would lead to
a turnover and what I saw out of
spagnolo on Sunday in quarters two three
and four was I saw a quarterback
coordinator go let's make them drive the
field that's the opposite of what you
want I would rather the Chiefs allow a
40-yard touchdown and get the ball back
to mahomes then allow a nine play drive
that ends in a touchdown make make them
hit the throw deep make them do that do
not let teams control the ball against
you well that's that's what's been
happening make them lob it up there and
maybe your cornerback gets a pick well
that's what's been happy I think you've
got to give up the run bring pressure
bring because you know what those bags
does maybe you stopped the run by
Blitzen he's a Jim Johnson disciple he's
a special type of guy anymore figure it
out yeah NFC East there's two three and
three teams you don't have to take one
of those mmm you could take the two and
four Giants the only one game back [ __ ]
you could hate the one v Washington they
are
all the right there I mean it's not who
was you heck Wow
I'm gonna go Eagles here okay means I
will be arguing for the Cowboys what is
your reasoning for the Eagles as the
best team in the NFC I don't know that
here's a deal I think Carson is playing
good at some point you get DeSean
Jackson back at some point out Sean
Jeffery will be healthy and some at some
point Zach Ertz is gonna show up this
season and you know they went through
their deal with a the players on the
team felt that they were passing the
ball to earth too much and Carson is
kind of separating himself for that go
back to throwing the ball to earth and
if the easy only guy open just keep
throwing the ball to him just keep doing
that
I think the offensive line is relatively
healthy obviously Jason Peters meets
missed a big part of the game yesterday
that that's gonna be a concern
defensively losing Nigel Bradham is
scary is it that that's the scary part
for you know their secondary is scary
however crow Vaughn LeBlanc is coming
though they'll get they'll get Ronald
Darby back they'll get jaylen Mills back
a lot lock yeah he'll come back at some
point so don't get a little bit
healthier in the secondary
maybe they trade someone I just think
that Carson is probably the best
quarterback in there in their division
defensively they will play better
they got exposed a little bit against
the Vikings that's gonna be a problem
the Dallas Cowboys have a big problem
though and that's why I like to equals
they have a big problem they can't
protect the quarterback they can't get
their running game going because of that
and defensively where they were good
last year at the Dallas Cowboys they're
just not there notice they're not a
solid defensively if I had to argue for
the Cowboys you say if to Sean John's
DeSean Jackson comes back what is he
gonna play one game and then mix the
miss the next hopefully a couple
everyone's talking about how Dallas has
played weak opponents the opponents
they've played thus far have
collectively 13 wins okay the opponents
the Eagles have played collectively thus
far 13 wins okay so it's not like
they've played that much more of a more
difficult schedule they are going to get
some guys back
Tyron Smith Lyle Collins that will make
that offensive line back hole to where
they were in their three-game winning
streak and it should give the Cowboys a
better chance to get the offense flowing
and we saw with this defense last year
they
and adjust to stop doing the same damn
thing Rod Marinelli every single game
and actually adjust them also as I
mentioned the beginning of the year a
number of players that were prominent
for them - Markus Lawrence Byron Jones
coming off offseason surgeries they
could be better but if I had to be
honest I think the Eagles yeah because
the Cowboys have played the second
easiest schedule in the NFC and from
week 7 to 16 so next weekend on they
face the toughest schedule in the NFL
it's about to get wild for the Cowboys
yes yeah I also think that the Eagles
have a better coach I'm gonna tell you
this
I think the Eagle I agree with you they
had the better coach I think Jerry Jones
messed up this entire team here's the
reason why yeah let's hear it yeah you
had the big contract dispute between him
Zeke obviously week to week for over a
decade and I was goes away it was really
the first three weeks yeah yeah yeah but
but yeah it's gone away because they're
not talking about it anymore but DAC it
hasn't gone away from him me just
imagine confidence in and going out
there momentum all those different
things you said you went through that I
went through I went through a situation
where I didn't get the contract I held
out during training camp I didn't get
the contract and then it wasn't to the
mid mid seasons that I actually paid me
and so at some point you're discussing
it the entire time or whatever they were
they were discussing every no they were
yeah of course I talked to my agent
every day like yo what's the deal so you
think Dax to another you can't I don't
be doing it so I'm sure I'm sure he's
fit he's finding out from his agent like
oh what's the deal what's going on are
we gonna pay me did I have a great game
subconsciously or consciously you're
thinking about this every single game I
had a bad game I probably want to get 30
oh I had a good game I need 35 now I
mean you can't put your quarterback in
this position this is a mental position
this is a mental situation for your
quarterback the most important player on
your team and now you make them wait
that's crazy you can't put your team in
this situation because now you say hey
Zeke we don't have you at Camp because
we didn't want to pay you now he doesn't
look the same he doesn't look and say
office a lot doesn't look the same they
have no continuity or offensively unless
they play a bad team that's gonna be a
problem that's why you don't do that
an owner and I know you want to play the
game we don't want to pay we want to pay
you'll oh you went hi I understand that
yes but at some point that affects your
team and that's what's going on with the
Cowboys the team looks terrible right
now they're in an unwinnable situation I
think with that contract at the same
point they're gonna have to pay the kid
never had to pay him
and he has a plate like he should get
paid that I believe that dak is a very
good quarterback I don't believe he's
great but I believe he's very good he's
good again I would take dak over Jared
Goff if they're both under pressure one
of them is throwing a pick or getting
sacked the other can make a guy miss and
then still for the ball game mmm
sometimes it's as simple as that which
one of them has Jason Garrett the other
one has Sean McVeigh like I really don't
need to break this down mr. Saleh tutor
you like come on
but my other thing though is if somehow
like I would make dak of my franchise
quarterback would I pay him 35 million
dollars a year no I would that's the
going rate but here's the gotta go right
here is a deal if somehow they're able
to get him for a little bit less because
maybe this season doesn't go right maybe
instead of going ten and six the Cowboys
go 88 and they miss the playoffs
could it be possible that they're able
to pay dak a little bit less and they're
able to pay Omari a little bit less and
they're able to pay Byron Joe's a little
bit less and then the fear of pay and
dak and not getting able to keep the
rest of these guys they're able to keep
all of them in the long run that's a
better thing for the Cowboys I just I
don't know if dak is gonna go you you
made this bit of evaluating me week to
week you should still believe that I'm
worth 35 million no matter what yeah but
because that's what the position demands
and and for him to say hey it was at the
end of the season I was a temp best
quarterback I'll take 25 now or I'll
take 30 now that's crazy that doesn't
happen no agent says that because what
the agent will say is that well you know
what he was might have been the eighth
best quarterback in the league this year
but last year he was a 15th best and you
still were willing to pay him and next
year he'll be the fourth best right and
so he was not gonna stay the same he's
gonna continue to get better if I'm deck
I'm in no matter what
I'm not taking less that's not an option
for me know if you want me to take less
let me go yeah and see how that goes
that work when you do that negotiations
what have you done that before
I I was in the negotiation with Joe Ben
and I'm like and Joe banner his style
was like well you're not Tiki Barber
because you can't do this you're not
Marshall Faulk because you can't do that
and you're not this Stan the other
because you can't here's the only things
you're really good at and so my age I
told you like listen if it feels that
way then just tell them let me go and
I'll go find work somewhere else I
there's other there's a value for me in
other places if you don't think that I'm
valuable and I can't do all those things
I have enough to you to that then they
paid me yeah they baby because at some
point you got to say this is what I mean
to this team yeah I may not mean that
same thing to the the 49ers that want to
run power football every single play but
for this team you want a guy who's gonna
catch the ball out of the backfield it's
gonna block for your quarterback in the
ten twelve times they're gonna run the
ball the game that he can do that I fit
that mold the things when you talk about
the Dallas County my my name pay me my
money and and and when you talk about
the Dallas Cowboys first of all you got
to be able to establish establish the
run game they haven't done that all
season hell because the offensive line
because of Zeke coming back a little bit
slower they haven't established the run
so that play-action pass that you want
to get to you can't get to it because
you don't have the run game to support
that there's sometimes where dak hasn't
been as a Couric there's other times
when these receivers have just playing
out drop the football oh yeah well
simple as that that's not on deck you
don't blame it for that so again at the
end of the day Jerry's gonna have to pay
the going rate yes that's the gory uh in
terms of the best team in the NFC North
I don't think we can have this
discussion on this Monday we're gonna
see the Packers Lions tonight mm-hm to
me that division is too close because I
like unless you really believe that
Minnesota's have that much better than
Green Bay not for the game I I need to
see the game I can make the argument I
can make the argument show the Vikings
are the best but I think you have to you
have to wait and see the game but you
also got to say what I think about
defense is I think the the the Vikings
defense is a step ahead of the the
Packers would you agree with that a
little bit more physical I think the
Packers have played teams when they play
physical teams they can beat up a little
I believe the Vikings have a better deal
ein and linebacking core they're the
Packers have a better secondary okay I I
agree with that I agree with that um but
I believe that the the Vikings have a
better defensive play caller
but I also go the Bears have better
defense in all of them that's true
they don't have they'd only have a close
even a comparable offense and I think
maybe they'll figure out something to
buy I doubt it but to me the north like
that's the hardest division to pick
right now is the NFC no-good division
NFC South I have already said that I
believe the Saints are gonna win the
Super Bowl I mean the only other
discussion there is the Panthers I think
they're a very good team I think they
have their sights set on the playoffs
but I can't really make an argument for
the Panthers
the only thing question I'd like to ask
you is with Kyle Allen now going for and
oh and with rumors starting to come out
that could the Panthers trade Cam Newton
yeah
are there any way is there any way that
this could happen
are there any teams that you think you
could be traded to can I float three
teams to you to see what your opinions
load them okay if there is truth to the
Cam Newton trade rumors I have three
interesting team are we talking with in
season trades or after the season
whatever you want it okay it doesn't
matter
let's go after the season bears would be
very interesting I think that would be a
great tree that incredible defense with
Cam Newton on offense with that sort of
handoff fake rip off an incredible tree
like it Steelers mm-hmm
Ben's gonna come back Cam Newton is
really just a younger cooler bang oh no
you know well it was cam gonna play
second string oh no I mean Ben's dead
he's gonna be tutored under Ben that
ain't been said it been said he's coming
back okay
and he's coming back can't wait to see
that off offseason diet regimen if he
wants he wants that money is what I
heard him saying tonight when I xx when
I hear him say no I'm coming back but
he's next two years from the contract
that that says to me I want their money
and then the one that I think I'm most
excited about I think even more so than
the Bears what if he went what if Cam
Newton was traded to the team that he
lost to in the Superbowl the Denver
Broncos so he goes to a Rick scangarelo
Kyle Shanahan offense and with Phillip
Lindsay and Royce Freeman yeah with
what's blossoming into a real number one
in the NFL in Cortland son
they've invested young draft picks in
their offensive line and tight end no
offense and their defense with Vic
Fangio is always gonna find a way to
keep it low he has a very good friend on
the team in Von Miller here and John
Elway is obsessed with tall quarterbacks
I think I still like Chicago but I think
that Denver would be very insight
because they they want to run the
football they want to use their short
gain with Lindsey out of the backfield
the obviously royce freeman pounding the
ball down the throat and they want to
play defense yeah so I think in a
situation where cam isn't always the
most inaccurate yeah he doesn't have to
he doesn't have to throw the ball 30
times a game and win a game that way I
think that might work
well I also Karason Broncos kind of feel
good for cam to get out of Carolina it'd
be a good thing I think he's this is
what this is what I keep hearing from
people that play with Cam is that cam
isn't a great leader that concerns me a
little bit and he has to be the leader
of that football team
you know Kuechly on the defensive side
of the ball offensively he's the guy
they say that cams not a great leader
like he's sleeping him meaning he's
wearing a hoodie
he just doesn't to that point I read an
article about the Patriots on Sunday
that David Andrews who was the center
that's now on the IR has become another
coach he's at every practice and he's at
every meeting is every walkthrough and
he's become another coach I have not
heard that one time about cam and Kyle
yeah I just mean if I've missed it
that's my ignorance and I apologize I
have not seen a single image of cam on
the sideline with Kyle yeah looking over
the place well they just seen cam
release his own video saying hey when we
lost I was really hurt then right right
right
well so we have to give a little letter
by saying maybe he's doing it we don't
know about it maybe maybe he's behind
the scenes doing it and I just heard a
lot of bad things about cam and I don't
know the kid and I don't know anything
other than what I've been told for
people that play with them but I think
that he probably needs a new start and I
think if you talk about Denver or
Chicago both cold-weather cities were
you gonna have to play outside in the
cold we have a big six five quarterback
running down you
throat that's gonna be problems for
defense the reason I think it's gonna
get really bad I saw Steve Smith on TV
get asked about it and he skirted the
question complains about what asked
about what would you do in a hooter cow
and he pretty much like a lot of people
down there talking yeah bah-bah-bah and
I was like oh that's weird and he played
with Canton number two Luke Kuechly was
asked before the game by one of the
reporters hey you know if if when if cam
comes back what do you do and Luke
Kuechly gave this line I'm glad I don't
have to make that decision what it was
it's simple what because if cam was
still the guy the defensive captain
alongside of him would go me and cam
have been at this together for like
eight years he's the guy I just looked
up I just typed in Cam Newton Kyle Allen
and the first thing is to run Rivera
about that I'm not gonna get into it
right now why should you this is going
to get ugly because a large portion of
NFL fans have always disliked cam from
how he looks
there's a thing online right now where a
picture of Christian McCaffrey was put
up before the game and there was an
inordinate amount of white Panthers fans
that wrote you look very professional
Christian McCaffrey we all know what
they're hinting at you can't get angry
at me I don't really care open up your
eyes at the same point in the Superbowl
when he didn't dive on that fumble who
everybody came for his neck it was
pent-up frustration they should have
done that but that that really was like
we got a problem here
yeah I don't know if it's real I don't
know if it's people that just don't like
cam but this is going to get very ugly
well to just imagine this just imagine
what you're saying yeah I your eye test
would tell you the truth that you have a
team that went oh and two with Cam and
you got a backup young kid that just
went for No
and he's just he's throwing slants the
DJ more the occasional deep fade to
Curtis Samuel the one can he lure
McCaffrey better than cam is that he's
not improvising he's running the offense
as it was constructed in a lot of
backups that don't have the same
mobility he'll never be the same athlete
gets camp he'll never be able to run
people over make people miss do all
those different things
however he has to use his skill set that
he has this would kind of Alan does one
two three ball now one two three four
five ball now the ball is supposed to be
there at the receivers not at that point
then it's just the end completion to me
it's something that it was we saw this
with Aaron Rodgers a lot last year where
because the offense sucked for so many
years the scheme
he'd have to hold on to the ball longer
and he'd he'd have to throw it away
sometimes and then last year or even in
this especially this year there have
been times where we've seen him arguing
with Matt Lafleur and so I sympathize
with these quarterbacks sometimes
because when luck with Cam Newton where
they had shitty offensive lines for a
bunch of those years and he had to make
the plays turning that switch off and
just running the plays it's almost like
you have PTSD so you're like what to do
every time I do this I get punched in
the mouth and now you want me to do it
and so I understand why it's a tough
transition but it's very hard I would
still take care if I was on that
football team and let's just say this is
my last year playing we can't go back to
camp Wow would you how could what Wow if
let's just say Callum wins another the
next two games right so he's won six
games in a row can it cams healthy now
cam I love you I love you as a person
and I think you're a great guy but we
can't stop the momentum we can't stop
the train
you're gonna Alec Smith him I want you
to play Whitley hey we're hot right now
what happens if we win six in a row and
we go back to you and then we lose did
we go back to Carroll Allen well no that
does know how it works if you go with
the hot hand and I'm the old school says
you know what you don't lose your
position due to injury unfortunately if
you win six games in a row you lose your
position that's what happens yeah it is
interesting I I would take in the bill
Barnwell to you this is turd a healthy
Kyle Allen is better than injured cam
healthy cam is better than healthy Kyle
Allen if cam coming back completely
healthy oh you would assume do you know
what that's my plea to Kim is I hope cam
and drew brees both don't rush this pass
come back completely both of your backup
quarterbacks have you guys for know in
your abs rice
don't let this feast on your ego don't
let this make you go at home and wonder
do they need me
both teams while winning need you and so
come back a hundred percent healthy
mm-hmm it's like paternity leave just
take your time take your time
that was my get forever dad was here but
I can also see cam coming back and went
in a couple games because he because now
teams have forgotten how they won well
cam running around a little bit if he
could be that old Cammy was two years
ago yes that's a difference maker all
right let's wrap it up with this best
team in the NFC West Seahawks okay
you go first proven commodity have done
it before they led by a great leader in
Russell Wilson they're led by a great
coach in it's the kids the guys Kyle
Shannon no Lady Hawks Pete Carroll oh my
gosh I'm drawn to play but they're led
by a great coach Pete Carroll
I think they put out some they put out
around some around Russell Wilson some
pretty good weapons they run the
football efficiently I think their
defense can get after the quarterback
best one of the best linebacker course
in the game I'm concerned a little bit
about their secondary but they play hard
and I think they played their scheme
very very well and if you have to go to
Seattle to play you're in trouble one of
the loudest stadiums in the NFL hmm
commodity if I'm arguing for the Niners
the Seahawks have faced past defenses
that have been the top-ten easiest so
maybe that's how we explain in Russell
Wilson it's about to go from the top 10
to about the drop 10 spots and
difficulty perhaps I'll run the bald end
though I look at the Seahawks and as you
said before thought one two three four
five of their six games have been
determined by less than a touchdown so
we're not really seeing them handling
business whereas if you look at the
Niners
they went beat the Rams by 13 they beat
the Browns by 28 they beat the Bengals
by 24 and they beat the Buccaneers by 14
so for their five games they've won by
double digits I look at the Niners and I
go I believe that Russell Wilson is
Elite I believe he is special I believe
he is the MVP but I also believe that
the Niners are uniquely built to contain
him and I think that they're the perfect
matchup to shut him down
I believe that Kyle Shanahan is a better
offensive coach than anybody on the
seahawks whether it's offense or defense
and I believe that the Niners defense is
an elevated version of what the seahawks
defense he used to be that's where I
would stop pedigree they've been there
they've done that for sure that's
important if I was arguing for the
Seahawks Niners have played the easiest
schedule the NFL easier than New England
yeah also the Niners have faced a
collection of run offenses that have
been the top 10 easiest and they we know
that the Seahawks can pound the rock you
mentioned something that's just nonsense
yeah tell me though they can't handle
business what do you mean winning is
handling business that the score doesn't
matter
they won by two points they won by a
half a horse of course that's handling
business winning to bring up nonsense
like that no I'm just saying that so as
I mentioned before that teams that win
in one score games it's not something
that usually continues and so I brought
up the statistic last week about the one
win teams and I put out something
yesterday about how flippant that is
that last year the four teams that won
the most one win games have been
struggling this year
hmm last year the teams that won the
most one score games Dallas the Rams
dolphins and Chargers they went 28 and 6
yes this year the last year last year
right this year they are 2 and 8 in
those games yeah but we're talking about
this year I know the thing that you're
trying to do is is will the Seahawks be
one of those 9 & 1 teams in one score
games or do you look at them and go
therefore and one in one score games
that will likely even itself out as the
season goes on no no your stat talks
about the following year sure we're
talking about this year we're not
talking about 2020 we talk about 2019
listen so you listen the plastics I'm
just using them to get to be right he's
numbers lie these numbers a little
misleading here but uh 28 and 6 to me
those teams to me of
all the ones all the battles other than
the entire division that is the NFC
North the one that I'm most intrigued by
is the Niners and the Seahawks because
of the the Legion of Bloom because of
the Niners and Kyle Shanahan looking for
revenge I mean they're up 20 to 3 on the
Browns and everyone's making jokes about
how Kyle Shannon it's gonna blow this
lead right and I'm letting you know that
Kyle Shannon is probably woken up every
morning like [ __ ] John wick yeah and
it's like I'm gonna kill everybody what
do you think has happened to the Rams
are they completely out can the NFC West
get to wild cards or the Rams done I
have an enormous concern with the Rams
right now I just want to look at their
upcoming schedule and see if they're
playing teams that can expose it I
believe that their offensive line is
trash but I believe this is my
prediction and it's not a very bold one
they are gonna go into their week 9 by
week right now there are three and three
they're gonna be five and three okay
they're playing Atlanta and they're
playing Cincinnati easy one Atlanta is a
beautiful remedy yes they're gonna trade
this ailing you but after that Steelers
Bears Ravens Cardinals Seahawks Cowboys
Niners two Cardinals dusters and my
issue for the Rams as I said before if
their offensive line is a mess and Jared
Goff is a bottom five quarterback under
pressure I don't give a [ __ ] what play
calls you gotten because if I'm in his
face he sucks
it's not about golf the golf has not
been good golf golf golf job saying yeah
well I'll tell you this if they can't
run the football
Jared golf is an average quarterback and
if they don't have Gurley back there
their average football team because
defensively they can't stop him and when
teams realize that don't run at Aaron
Donald get run on the outside away from
them and the two teams that have done
that to him in the last three weeks the
Tampa Bay Buccaneers and the Niners
Chris Carson they just run him into your
face and you deal with it but the
Buccaneers and the Niners were able to
run to the outside wherever they wanted
and the Niners did it without either
tackle or their fullback wake the [ __ ]
up it's scary time Brian Westbrook this
is a very productive podcast today you
get a lot we covered a lot today you
know what we made
one dollar bet yes the Patriots are
going the Super Bowl we learned that you
doubt Bill Belichick which is phenomenal
and we've officially named you the
president of the Kirk Cousins think let
me in Kirk Cousins about yourself going
all the way brother
for Brian Westbrook the Rocket Man
I am the lef koe Man and we will holla
holla holla at you later please
[Music]